hallo mein name ist luca wird von vielen
der sesamstraße spieler empfohlen da es
wohl genau von der altersklasse auf mich
begrenzt wäre alles klar das pinkfarbene
haus ganz rechts mit der kuppel und den
ist das kino danke okay das ist auf
jeden fall super dass du mir alles
versuchen beizubringen
hier haben wir wert und wir haben hier
solche kino es ist super dass du mir
alles sagt aber ich glaube ich kann das
ganze fand ich weiß nicht was ich machen
kann wie jeder einfach mal hier oben auf
ehrenwert und jetzt können wir hier guck
mal wer da ist
guten tag guten tag was machen die mit
den händen wenn man da drauf klickt kann
man filme sie dass es filme anschauen
wow es macht spaß hier bei den filmen
sind fotos von all unseren freunden aus
der sesamstraße was sind denn das für
das ist das sind ja noch schönere mal
was war das
ist das alles aus gottes sind voll die
erinnerung wieder hochkommen aus der
sesamstraße a
den tristen tag im spielehaus spiele
spielen nach dem schönsten ist es in
demand mitspielt das wort schief singt
ich ein leeres blatt sie kann ich gar
nicht anders und ich muss das wunder
vollbringt mein kunstwerk ist vollendet
kann ich das jetzt veröffentlichen ich
kann es ausdrucken
das ist nicht wahr tatsache ich kann es
ausdrucken alter was ist denn das okay
wenn ich irgend jemand fragt was macht
kommen kräfte eigentlich auf youtube sag
ihm einfach es spielt das lesen straße
spiel mal dort einen haufen scheiße und
druckt sich denen dann auch mein gott er
kommt er kommt er kommt zu hat schießt
du scheiße es kam leeres blatt raus das
ist doch nicht wahr die sind ich würde
ich für meine kunst nie wieder mal ich
euch einen scheiß teilen was können wir
denn sonst noch mal raus das ist nicht
wahr ich guck dir diese scheiß fair das
hat zwei verschiedene orte besucht die
gemüse partner zu spielen das gemüse
liegt auf dem herd spielen sucht das
ehepaar spiel es ist multerer als algen
börse
und was ist ohne als eine paprika kinder
zwei paprika also in diesem spiel gibt
es von allem
guck mal wir klopfen stapel neben mir
dann geht's los
du kannst die x 2 karten gleichzeitig
auf dem feld geführt
das ist doppelt lecker dass du keine
lust mehr weiterzuspielen doch ich finde
dieses wertes hammer die auen preis oder
so wenn du zwei gleiche karten gefunden
ich muss mich noch mal dass du lust
nochmal zu spielen nein verkaufen kann
mir da irgendwie was man spielen das
freut mich sie hättest du mal
vorbeischaut
es gibt doch nichts schöneres als ein
spaziergang im freien
ich muss den arbeiten den richtigen sinn
jetzt geht nach hause
durch das labyrinth zeigen so schick wie
viele ameisen weil das wird ja immer
anspruchsvoller hier
ich glaube irgendwann packe ich ein
level einfach gar nicht mehr was ist
denn jetzt rein theoretisch wenn ich
hier die ganze zeit in eine falsche
richtung laufen oder mal wieder hier
oben da mal wieder hier zurück damit er
hier lange und jetzt durchlaufen die
herausbewegen so da willst du noch mal
nein ich will nicht nochmal ich möchte
mir hier was ist denn mit dem kino ich
muss kein geheimnis
merkel darf die studenten wieder der
braune bär am anfang war gar nicht
krümelmonster sonne krümelmonster ist
der blau ich mich voll vertan
auch jetzt kann ich mir hier wieder so
ein paar filme von denen eigentlich in
unserer ganzen schwachsinn aber freuen
ich würde sagen dass war es mit diesem
sesamstraße video wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen wir sehen uns sonsten im nächsten
video wieder schreibt mir weitere
behinderte spielen die kommentare ich
fand es total witzig irgendwie und dann
will ich bergen